3-2 ثمين لا أرى أين هو
الصنبور
[موسيقى]
3 2 أخيرًا 25
انطلاق
م
كابانو ألفا الثلاثي موضوع لالا منارة
كوم منطقة ألينا فينال الأسرة الأمريكية
يعلق انتمائه إلى الحياة
مثل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الرهانات السرية في مهمات التصوير
وهو ما يتطلب كليهما تمامًا
مستوى جودة الصورة من
له وإذا أخذنا واحدًا منه
أضواء الخ مضاءة الصيد كل شيء
ما هو الضوء يغير واحد
تأثير الصورة
ستعرض السحابة تلقائيًا ملف
صورة أغمق قليلاً و
مشاهدة نرى الفرق بين
الاثنين لذا علينا أن نكرر
مرور حيث كان هناك تغيير
ضوء العاكس c1 بالتأكيد نحن
يلتقط الشمس و
إعادة التوجيه إلى الموضوع حيث الشخص
أننا نجري مقابلة معها
مات غرفة عند وصول هؤلاء
يقطع ويخلق رمل الملابس الداخلية لا
أكثر مثل هذا أكثر
[موسيقى]
من هذا القبيل أو أكثر من هذا القبيل
يحتوي على الميكروفون
[موسيقى]
نحن
وفي الساعة 8 مساءً والنهر
[موسيقى]
الى
نعم
يمكنه أن يتخيل أن إطلاق النار
تفعل في لقطة واحدة
نادرا ما يكون هذا هو الحال حتى من لديه
يمكن أن يتم ذلك عشر مرات أو مرة واحدة
خمسة عشر مرة حسب
العناصر التي يمكننا الحصول عليها أولاً
مأخوذة بسحابة عابرة
الثانية مع طائر سيارة
بعد مشكلة من جملتين أو
كلمات منسية أو أشياء من هذا القبيل
صحيح أنه يمكن تكراره من
مرات عديدة في الرأس
[موسيقى]
سألت السيدة زين من أم مالي
في إحدى الصور التي قمنا بها هناك
ليس بالضرورة وقتًا طويلاً حيث كنا
وجدت في منطقة بها حفل زفاف
مع انتهاء التعرض بـ
لو بقينا أعتقد أنه
بين 4 و 5 ساعات في الموقع بدون
لتكون قادرًا على الحصول على صورة واحدة
صالح للإستعمال
[موسيقى]
برج سانت جاك
لماذا يلوم airtel كل شيء
ماتالون فاطمة تجد سيدتي إذا كنت
تريد إعادته من إنجلترا أصغر
ما لم يصبح فظيعة
هي
[موسيقى]
لذلك يذهب بسرعة وإطلاق النار
متعب للغاية لأنه لا يزال لدينا
الكثير من المواد لتحملها
عدة مرات يجب أن تقول ما بين 20 و 30
الحد الأدنى من الكيلوغرامات من المواد المراد نقلها
لذا نعم هذا مادي مصنوع من
بن عروس
لا
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا أبي
وداعا شكرا لقدومك
هذا جيد
شكرا و إلى اللقاء
[موسيقى]